now remarks by the founder and retired
chairman of the vanguard family of
mutual funds
john bogle at the national press club
yesterday he talked for about an hour
about the future of private investment
and took questions from the press club
audience
good afternoon and welcome to the
national press club
i'm john obashon i'm senior
correspondent for newsnite maryland on
maryland public television and vice
president
of the national press club i'd like to
welcome club members and their
guests in the audience today as well as
those of you watching on c-span
or listening to this program on national
public radio
the video archive of today's luncheon is
provided by connect live
and is available through the national
press club website
at npc.press.org
national press club luncheons are also
carried live by many sites on the world
wide web
press club members may also access
transcripts of our luncheons
at our website non-members may purchase
transcripts audio and videotapes
by calling 1-888-343-1940
before introducing our head table i
would like to remind our members
of future speakers tomorrow march 22nd
veteran journalist bill moyers will join
us his topic
what i would have told stephanopoulos if
only he had asked
on thursday march 29th former senator
sam nunn
will speak on new challenges to u.s
national security
on tuesday april 3rd ted forestman
senior partner enforcement at little and
chairman of and ceo parents in charge
will be our
guest if you have questions for our
speaker please write them on the cards
provided at your table and pass them up
to me i'll try to ask as many as time
permits
i'd like now to introduce our head table
guest and ask them to stand briefly when
their names are called please hold your
applause
until all headtable guests are
introduced
from my left your right first patrice
hill
washington times
ken moritzuhu knight ritter
finlay lewis of copley newspapers
siobhan hughes bloomberg financial news
owen allman washington editor of usa
today and editor
of the international economy
andrew bogle son of the speaker
david hess former national club national
press club president and
co-chairman of the speakers committee
don kopecki of dow jones
mike mcnamee of businessweek
michelle singletary of the washington
post
robert mcmillan washington bureau chief
of newsbites.com
and fred fraley kiplinger's personal
finance magazine
john c bogle senior jack bogle is
one of the modern mutual fund industries
founding fathers
and one of its harshest critics
fortune magazine picked him as one of
four wall street giants of the 20th
century and
barons put him on its all century team
and yet by his own admission
mr bogle is never going to win a
popularity contest among his
wall street peers john vogel has been
helping
other people make money on the market
since 1951.
fresh out of princeton armed with his
senior thesis
on mutual funds than an obscure
financial instrument
somewhat he joined wellington management
and
16 years later he was running the place
in 1974 he founded the vanguard group
which included wellington in a blatant
display of age discrimination mr
bogle finally retired as senior chairman
of vanguard in 1999
at the young age of 70 years and since
then he has continued to launch rockets
at the practices of contemporary fund
managers
vogel is the average investors champion
he invented the pro-consumer practice of
no-load funds that gave
investors a fair shake on their money
he pushed an idea that at the time was
heresy the market indexed fund
that pooled investors money and
carefully selected groups of stocks to
reduce risk
and all the while he insisted even
demanded that his managers and
publicists be open
and candid with investors about the
risks of investing what a concept
his critics came to refer to him
sarcastically as saint jack
bogle himself saw that as proof that he
was
doing what was best for people who put
faith in his company
he is still at it today his targets are
high management fees high expenses
high portfolio turnover and to focus on
marketing
rather than investing when vogel started
vanguard in 1974 the total assets of the
then new venture were roughly
1.5 billion dollars the wellington fund
itself
still in the vanguard family accounted
for 900
million well today vanguard commands 109
domestic funds and 33 abroad
with 580 billion of its shareholders
money under its management
the wellington fund alone is worth 23.4
billion
and its bogle invented 500 index fund
manages 90.5 billion so his do good
approach obviously had some merit
we at the national press club attribute
mr bogle's success to the fact that he
is a former reporter
he was a stringer for the philadelphia
bulletin while in college
and a gale group biography tells this
story about his newspapering experience
early one morning the police told bogle
about a house fire
and exhausted from a night of reporting
and chasing sources around the city on
the trolley
bogle decided to call the story into the
paper
without going to the scene
quiz about details of the fire and the
color of the house
by the desk editor bogle became
embarrassed at his obvious
shoddy work he learned an enduring
lesson
quote not just to tell the whole truth
and nothing but the truth he told author
robert slater
more than that the lesson was to skip
the shortcuts
so now to tell the whole truth and skip
the shortcuts about wall street's future
i give you john c
bogle
thank you jim thank you so much john
that's a
a lovely introduction uh with a story
that is unfortunately true
i couldn't help thinking as i came down
in this rainstorm today
that there must be some similarity
between the weather and the stock market
and i thought the storm was bad outside
until i got inside here and looked at
the quotations
and i'm going to talk a little bit
with some numbers to you today and we
will have a handout
copy of of the charts some charts and
some things that will go with this
speech if any of you're interested after
the talk
so don't be disturbed if you can't stay
with the numbers i'd like to rely on
facts where i possibly can
and i begin the speech by saying wow
late last december when i accepted your
invitation to speak i selected the title
after the fall what's next for the
mutual the stock market in the mutual
fund industry
uh reflecting my expectations the stock
market would continue to fall but i can
tell you
that i did not expect it to fall this
far and this fast
when i picked that title however stocks
since i picked that title stocks have
moved into
the worst bear market a decline of at
least 20 percent from the high
since 1987 and the second longest bear
market
since the 21 month 21 month
50 percent drop from 1973 1974.
since the highs last year the aggregate
value of u.s equities
has now tumbled by almost a cool
5 trillion dollars from 17 trillion a
year ago
just a little bit over 12 trillion today
that's a market and a half
driven by technology stocks the nasdaq
index as you know is
tumbled from 5048 a year ago to
well 1850 or so yesterday 63
and obviously the bubble in the new
economy stocks has burst
the standard poor's 500 index much
broader representation of the total
market
is now off probably 27 from its high
technology stocks to give you an example
of what's driving this market
with 34 of the s p 500 a year ago
they're 18
just about half that amount today
how do you get these bubbles well in
this case a once in a generation
combination of a booming economy and the
optimism of a new millennium
the abuleans engendered by a quarter
century without a single protracted
market decline
a time of unity mostly in the u.s and
peace
mostly around the globe robust growth
in corporate earnings but not without
some awfully aggressive earnings
management
and the siren song of a new era
the information age the new paradigm
with growth projections for high-tech
companies that lost all touch with
reality those are the ingredients
and truth told it was not very difficult
to see it all coming
indeed right at the high of the market a
year ago i gave a speech entitled risk
control in an era of greed pointing out
that reward is at its pinnacle
risk is near at hand reminding my
audience
of a quote from the roman article cato
2200 years earlier
listen to this in view of today's market
there must certainly be a vast fund of
stupidity in human nature
else men would not be caught as they are
a thousand times over
by the same snare and while they yet
remember their past misfortunes
go on to court and encourage the causes
to which they were owing
and which will once again produce them
end of cato quote quote from bogle
looking at the stock market a year ago
so let me be clear march of 2000
you can place me firmly in the camp of
those who were deeply concerned the
stock market is all too likely to be
riding for a painful fall
a fall that may well have begun as i
began to write this speech ten days ago
viewed a decade hence today's stock
market may be just one more chapter
in extraordinary popular delusions and
the madness of crowds
now it was just dumb luck that my timing
was so prescient but like most
investment professionals i think
we have a pretty good idea of what is
going to happen in the markets
even if we have little if any idea of
when
nobody knows that nonetheless i'm going
to take a look today
at what we might expect from the stock
market during the coming decade
to do so i want to talk about some very
important fundamentals
that you'll just have to bear with me on
because you can't understand the markets
if you can't understand what i'm saying
the mathematics of the market are
eternal complex and mysterious as the
stock market may seem its returns are
determined
by the elementary internet interaction
of just two simple elements
albeit two elements whose qualities are
different as night from day
the first is investment return
determined by dividend yields
and earnings growth investment return
tends to be
recurrent and steady the second is
speculative return
reflected simply in a change in the
price earnings multiple
price that investors willing to pay for
a dollar of earnings speculative return
is intermittent and spasmodic
add them together we have the market
return
it's that simple it really is and over
time
it is earnings and dividends investment
return
that determine all of the return that is
achieved
by the stock market consider the past 40
years
dividend yields plus earnings growth
over that period came to a total of 11.2
percent
the actual return of the stock market
was an identical 11.2
percent per year in the long run as it
turns out
earnings and dividends call the market
tune
but speculative return can be the
driving force over short term and even
over extended periods
for example in 1961-81 the first half of
that 40-year period
the pe fell from 22 to 8 times resulting
in a speculative return of minus
four percent per year four and a half
percent a year
reducing the investment return of 12
percent then to a market return of seven
and one half
12 minus four and a half during the
second half of the period 1981
to yesterday the period in which most
americans have gained their
investment experience the p e ratio
soared
to as high as 33 before retreating to
the present level of 24
still enough to add five percentage
points a year
in specula of return raising the annual
investment return
to a market return of 15
now think about what i've just told you
despite the all-time market returns high
market returns were reveled in in the
past 20 years
the fundamentals of earnings and
dividends were actually a bit lower
than in the previous 20-year period 10
versus 12.
but the annual report market return more
than doubled
from 7 to 15. why simply because the
pendulum of market speculation
which pulled returns down as it swung
from the grand abelliance of 1961 to the
pessimism of 81
sam returned soaring as it swung back to
the roaring optimism that culminated
just as we celebrated the new millennium
a year early i should note
and what a difference it made consider
the magic of compounding on an
investment return over each of those two
20-year periods the 1961
investor earned seven and a half percent
and enjoyed thirty two thousand dollar
profit
the end of the period the 1981 investor
earned 15 percent
a 140 000 profit
by march 2001. that remarkable increase
from 32 000 to 140 000
came not from higher corporate profits
or dividends
not at all actually they were lower but
solely
because of a change in investor
attitudes the point
is that the economics of market return
the earnings and dividends of americans
corporations over two centuries
have always been both predictable almost
always and productive
the emotions of market return on the
other hand the price that investors will
be willing to pay
for each dollar of earnings are
unpredictable
sometimes productive sometimes
remarkably counterproductive
i use this dramatic example of the two
forces that determine stock returns
i call it the oasis of investment versus
the mirage of speculation
mirage that's fading as we speak today
to look ahead and consider what we might
find in the coming decade
we begin with a yield dividend yield of
only one percent a fraction of the
historical norm
of four percent to put it bluntly that
is not a lot of gas
in the stock market's tank but if we
assume that corporate earnings growth
will continue at seven percent
annual rate historic stocks would enjoy
an investment return investment return
of eight percent annually during the
coming decade
will speculative return enhance or
reduce that figure that's the question
before the house
if investors continue to pay 24 times
earnings as they do today
that market return will be the self same
eight percent per year that's what the
market holds for us
if the p e goes to 18 times drops
that would result in a negative
speculation
return speculative minus three percent
bringing that eight percent down to just
five percent if on the other hand the p
e were to rise to 30
we'd have a positive speculative return
two percent bringing the market's return
to ten percent
i think the current p e of 24 cannot be
sustained i think it's more likely to go
down and go up
and therefore i believe that five
percent is a much better guess
than 10 percent as the future market
return warren buffett by the way uses a
very
similar different different i should say
but equally disciplined methodology
and he comes up with an estimated return
in that range five six percent
you'll have to decide how much comfort
you want to take from the fact that
bogel
and buffett agree i wouldn't take too
much from it maybe we'll be
wrong on the low side what you might ask
would it take to produce another fifteen
percent return in the coming decade
it's easy assuming the investment return
is eight percent
it would require a speculative return if
you're sitting down of seven percent
that is it would require a final p e
ratio
of 47 times earnings to be clear
i don't think that number is remotely in
the cards
in short we have now departed a
two-decade-long golden era for equity
investors
in which we literally never had it so
good
and are entering an era in which the
party is over
alas i do not believe we have yet seen
the stock market's lows maybe today
though
for while we're approaching prices that
represent close to fair value i think
don't ever forget the market does
overdoes everything
that pendulum remember swung so far
above fair value
that when it comes back down it's not
going to stop there but it's have to get
to a very cheap level and overswing on
the downside as well
a new environment which for investing
which is more likely to be bland than
spicy
would not be without precedent for
example the dow jones
average was a thousand in 1966 it
touched that another
half a dozen times in the next 17 years
and was still a thousand in 1982 before
permanently moving upward
despite the prob the promise of jim
glassman's 36 dow 36
000 i think it's at least possible we'll
find the
market in the trading range say plus or
minus 25 from where we are today
of 10 000 not for 17 years probably but
for an extended period of time
it's possible but whatever returns the
market may deliver
don't make the mistake of thinking that
investors will actually earn those
returns
the fact is that few investors ever
capture 100
of the market's long-run annual rate of
return why simply because investing
costs money
the fact is that a huge proportion of
investment success
is represented by the allocation of
financial market returns between
investors in the one hand
and financial intermediaries and tax
collectors on the other
for investors as a group market returns
minus intermediation costs and taxes
equals investor return it is as simple
as that
costs matter they matter most where they
are one
very large two easily measurable
relative to the value of services
provided
and three compounded over time as you've
seen
and those are three of the defining
characteristics of the mutual fund
industry
fund costs are numerous and substantial
i might even say never ending
let me add them up management fees and
operating expenses now average one point
six percent a year
sales charges at least half a one
percent annualized
hidden portfolio transaction costs you
don't see these
with funds turning now turning over
their portfolios at a hundred percent
a year an absurd rate seven tenths of
one percent
one point six 0.5 seven that's six
two point eight percent a year and
another opportunity cost
of three tenths of one percent a year
because funds are rarely fully invested
in stocks
three tenths of one percent aggregate
cost three point one percent per year
that may not seem like much but it would
consume thirty one percent
of a ten percent market return throw in
the extra taxes investors are stocked
with
as a result of all that hyperactive
portfolio trading activity i'll come
back to that in a moment
could easily take in the current
environment another point and a half
percentage point and a half
leaving just one half of the mutual of
the market's annual return
for the fund investor if the return is
10 simply put
there are too many croupiers in the
mutual fund casino
and their rakes sweep too wide a swath
from financial
market returns fund investors have not
yet focused on the confiscatory power of
costs
why because the stock market's return
has been so generous
15 in the last decade meant that the
average mutual fund it won't surprise
you earn 15 percent before cost
but after cost and taxes in fact
delivered an estimated net return of
about nine percent
result ten thousand invested in the
average fund
profit of forty six thousand dollars a
lot of money
but less than one-third of the profit on
the stock market itself
which without costs or taxes grew by 154
thousand dollars instead of 46 000.
despite this abysmal shortfall however
fund investors i think
felt pretty comfortable because they'd
made a lot of dollars even though they
had not received a fair share
of the market's returns what happens if
the future market return
is five percent assuming that fund costs
don't decline
the tax costs do in a lower end return
environment the average fund investor in
a five percent market could receive a
one percent return with many
stockholders garnering negative return
five percent in the market may not seem
like much but it'll give you six
thousand dollars in a ten thousand
dollar investment a decade
at one percent it's a thousand dollar
profit for a decade of investment
i think disappointment would be far too
mild the characterization
of a shareholder's reaction so in a
future market environment of lower
returns
the confiscatory power of excessive
mutual fund costs
unless unnecessary taxes will severely
challenge this industry
in many respects this industry is a
child of the great bull market
of the past two decades that's why
equity funds have gone
up a hundred fold from 41 billion 20
years ago
to 3.7 billion trillion dollars today
but in a bland market in environment the
fund industry
face very serious challenges and will
have to get its act together
how significant reductions in management
fees are long overdue
and if fund directors lack the willpower
and knowledge to demand them
investors are going to finally vote with
their feet and abandon funds that hold
excessive costs
finally forcing down fund fees and
operating costs transaction costs and
other big costs must also decline as the
counterproductive short-term speculation
is the focus of so many fund portfolio
managers today the average fund
now holds an average position for 11
months
that we'll have to abate and once we
return to the industries once
traditional when i came into the
this business and when i wrote my
princeton thesis long-term orientation
when the average holding period of stock
was not
11 months but six years that's long
overdue and reduced not only
fund transaction costs but the heavy tax
burden that funds
that turnover force on unsuspecting fund
shareholders
it's not coincidental this gradual shift
from investment to speculation
has come hand in hand with a shift of
portfolio supervision and funds
from investment committees to portfolio
managers and then the following
development of a star system
alas however i must tell you the fund
industry has produced infinitely fewer
stars
than it has comets this
the devastating toll of this
extraordinary level of portfolio
turnover
is not possible to underestimate the
direct turnover cost themselves 28
billion last year paid to brokers market
makers
investment bankers but that's the least
of it despite the fact that last year
fund investors suffered 240 billion
dollars of capital losses last year
they received 345 billion of taxable
capital gains distributions
because the industry has this high
turnover and a third of those gains are
realized in a short-term basis
and taxed at ordinary income rates at
that unrecoverable tax cost
uh shareholders have
been suffering because the industry's
short-term investment strategies it's
not a good idea
central to the funds industry's problems
which the
john mentioned in the introduction is
the accumulation of assets under
management has become the name of the
game
the magnetic attraction the distribution
in the fun business has become
irresistible
and so it is that aggressive marketing
has long since
superseded prudent management as the
central ethic
of the mutual fund industry we all know
in the abstract here about marketing one
thing the best marketing
offering the public exactly what it
wants
and if it's ability in its ability to
follow the crowd the mutual fund
industry has few peers
if the investing public demands cake
well let them eat cake
the problem is the most desirable cake
is inevitably the cake that has been the
sweetest in the recent past
never mind that the exceptional past
returns some funds
achieved are all too rarely prologued to
exceptional future returns
indeed quite the reverse is true saint
matthew
had it right two thousand years ago
many that are first shall be last and
the last shall be first
you heard it here taken to its logical
conclusion such a marketing strategy
inevitably
places mutual fund managers in the wrong
place at the wrong time consider the
past decade
began in 1990 with stocks in the bargain
counter
yet the smallest component of the
industry 1.1 then trillion asset base
was in equity funds 25 percent of the
total bonds in money market funds
75 caution was the order of the day 10
years ago
for the investors and for the industry
now advance
the calendar to the first quarter of
2000. stock market had risen
500 percent in that period and was at
least in retrospect very richly valued
but the equity fund share had more than
doubled to 62 percent
of the industry's huge 6.3
trillion dollar base versus 38 percent
at the beginning up to 38 in in money
market and bond funds
down by half when stocks were nearly at
the cheapest levels in modern history
mutual funds had a 25 exposure to stock
market risk
when stock prices reached the dearest
levels ever recorded
taking into account the extra riskiness
which i'll comment on a moment of equity
fund portfolios
a 75 risk exposure three times as much
risk exposure as the high
as at the market low for that
counterproductive increase in risk we
can give much of the credit to the fund
industry itself
to understand what a marketing industry
become just consider
the shift in equity fund capital flows
during the years leading up to the stock
market peak last march
during the 90s net investor purchases of
u.s equity funds were almost exactly
divided evenly between
50 percent in relatively conservative
middle of the road value oriented stock
funds
and 50 percent riskier more aggressive
growth-oriented funds
but in 1999 the growth share leaped from
50
to 1990 to 92 percent and in the first
quarter of 2000
the growth fund share leaped to 113
percent of capital flows
on the other side of the coin the share
of cash flow into value funds dropped
eight percent in 1999
and to minus 37 during the first quarter
of 2000
that is in that first quarter investors
purchased 127 billion of the risky
growth funds
and liquidated 42 billion of the safer
value funds
at the very moment they should have been
minimizing risk
fund investors were maximizing their
speculative risk
clearly relative performance was the
reason growth in value funds provided
very similar returns from 1990 to 97
and then growth funds soared into the
lead through early 2000
providing annualized returns of 42
percent a year far ahead of 8
per year for the value funds but
reversion to the mean
that seemingly universal rule at the
last shall be first
the first should be last over and over
again promptly took over
and since last march growth funds have
declined 44
on average while value fund prices have
actually risen
by one percent it would be very easy
for the industry to argue that the
investor ever following past performance
following the crowd
is his own worst enemy but the industry
must bear a large share of the blame
first it pandered to the public taste by
creating 494 new growth funds
during the last 200 and two and a
quarter year period compared to just 110
value funds
second not only did funds vastly step up
their advertising budgets
to jump on the stock market to encourage
investors to jump on the market
bandwagon
but advertise the heady past performance
of some of the industry's hottest funds
with annual returns exceeding a hundred
percent
what's wrong with that well at least
these two things first winners rarely
have ever repeat and those are produced
advertisements
hyping past performance are every bit as
aware of that inevitable fact
as the countless academics whose studies
attest to it
second advertising is expensive directly
or indirectly it is the mutual fund
shareholder who puts
the advertising bill in the past two
years
the industry's seemingly unbridled
marketing budget likely included
a billion dollars for media advertising
alone
not including i hasten to add 120
million dollars
that one fund sponsor recently spent to
have a football stadium
carry its name imagine that
to put it bluntly fund shareholders had
a billion dollars of their money spent
on advertising
how this expenditure advanced their
interest or their returns
is certainly not clear to me this
marketing opportunism found its finest
and most perverse
focus in the fund industry's response
the information
revolution or more accurately to the
soaring returns generated by information
technology stocks
internet companies cell phone makers
computer manufacturers semiconductors
the works
during the early 1990s some of the years
one new technology fund was created some
years no new technology funds were
created
in 1999 29 new technology
funds created in the first quarter of
last year
71 more technology funds and investors
took the bait in the first quarter of
2000 technology funds alone
garnered 30 percent of the industry's
all-time record cash flow
of 113 billion dollars up to then
the returns on technology funds had
averaged
92 percent annualized
92 percent per year more than double the
returns even the soaring growth funds
but in the aftermath of the tech stock
boom tech stock
funds have dropped by 67 percent more
than half again the 44 percent i think
it was tumbling the weak growth fund
group
sweet marketing it turns out
is usually sour investing
the paradigm of the parrot of the
paradox time to sell funds is not the
time
to buy them not the time to buy them
came last march when a giant
brokerage firm sold its clients two new
era funds
an internet strategies fund and a focus
20 fund
right at the market's high at an
offering price
of ten dollars and fifty five cents per
share
appraised
at yesterday's close the net asset value
the internet fund was 2.44 cents a share
it was
the focus 20 fund 3.24 cents it was
by obliterating 1.4 billion dollars of
investor assets into thin air
this fund viewed at the time as a
marketing triumph has become at least
for the moment
an investment disaster and so the
chickens have come home to roost
and i hope it has not been gracious here
today to my host in the press if i point
out
that both the media's embrace of the new
economy and its focus on short-term
investment thinking and past performance
has helped lead mutual funds investors
astray and now that the party's over
i hope everybody in the room involved in
journalism will help to refocus the
attention of serious investors
on long-term investing on reasonable
expectations
on diversification and asset allocation
and cost
and tax efficiency standing up for those
eternal principles of investment success
would be an invaluable
public service the equity fund deck of
the huge mutual fund battleship by the
way with its high expenses excessive tax
costs short-term investment orientation
and marketing driven focus
is not the only deck of the battleship
in need of repair
the bond fund deck is another one
failing is the industry's near shunning
of
bond funds just when investors needed
them most
another is offering bond funds with such
high costs they deserve to be shunned
in a new environment which bond returns
are apt to be much more competitive with
stock returns
all the while carrying much lower risk
the industry will have to rectify these
failings
it's hard to overstate how much
refurbishing that deck of the industry
ship requires
excessive management fees and operating
expenses excessive portfolio turnover
costs
excessive sales charges wreak even
greater hardships on bond investors than
they do on stock investors
consider the simple mathematics today
the yield in the lehman aggregate bond
index is 6.6 percent
if an investor pays a four and a half
percent initial sale charge
and a one percent expense ratio and
holds the fund for five years
his average yield would be four point
six percent
two thirds of the return to the
shareholder one-third
to the group gaze and for a tax-exempt
bond fund the penalty is even greater
clearly that's a far cry from a fair
shake
and yet nearly half of the 1900 bond
funds in this industry carry a sales
charge
the average expense ratio is not 1.1
percent it's not 1
for 1.1 percent and only 75 of 1900
funds one out of 25
have expense ratios below three tenths
of one percent
my idea of a fair shake yet when
investors will turn to bond funds in the
new environments emerging
after the fall on the stock market
they'll have few choices that make even
the most tenuous economic sense
so in bond funds too the industry has
much more to do
to learn the loyalty and trust of fund
investors
now lest i paint the industry with too
broad a brush let me say there are some
firms that have resisted the temptations
that i've catalogued today some firms
that have won
minimized costly and aggressive
marketing two
shared at least some significant portion
of these staggering economies of scale
in this business
with investors by holding the line or
even reducing costs
three maintained investment discipline
in portfolio management and focused in
the long term
and four avoided the fads and fashions
of the day introducing new funds not
just because they make dollars
for the manager but because they make
sense
for the shareholder no firm i repeat no
firm
has a disciplined about a thousand in
this tough league but there are at least
a few that are batting upwards of 750
but painfully few out of the 400
complexes in this business today i don't
think i could name more than a dozen
that meet my high but i think reasonable
standards
let me wrap up with a confession because
i read somewhere that confession is good
for the soul
i confess that i make my remarks today
from a very singular
vantage point when i founded vanguard 26
years ago it was deliberately structured
as a mutual
mutual fund organization controlled not
by an outside management corporation by
the fund shareholders
themselves so cost obviously matters
i guess i've made that clear we operate
on at cost basis
and do not squander shareholder
resources on marketing
this focus this focus on the shareholder
quickly led me
to the founding of the industry's first
stock and bond market
index funds which do provide
substantially 100 percent of the
market's annual returns
and the elimination of all sales charges
it is putting the shareholder
first in everything we do that has been
the foundation of whatever success
vanguard may have enjoyed
so if the criticisms of the fund
industry i've expressed today sound
tough
it is not i assure you because of my
pugnacity
it is because of my perspective and
while few firms
will and indeed realistically few firms
can follow vanguard's example
any firm that wants to be a successful
in the new environment
after the fall as it has been in the old
environment before the fall
will have little choice but to take some
steps in our direction
it's high time this industry gets back
to the business
of prudent term investing
it's best unequivocally to place
stewardship
serving clients in the most honest
efficient and economical way possible
that's a little quote from my senior
thesis at princeton put that at the top
of the agenda
it's that single value the stewardship
of other people's money
that will place the mutual fund industry
and only that single value that will
place the mutual fund industry
on the right side of history thank you
very much
as you might imagine we have a few
questions
uh and it is probably no great surprise
to you
that a lot of the a lot of those in our
audience would like a little investment
advice
uh where where's the dell yeah
last month on lewis rookheiser you
summed up your uh
investment philosophy as buy everything
and hold it forever
do you do you still subscribe to that uh
in in light of
what the market has been doing or would
you unload some things now
no i i my theory is not subject to the
ups and downs the uh
peregrinations of the stock the
unpredictable perignations of the stock
market
uh it's painful to do but i think the
idea of owning the stock market is the
best approach to equity investing and
perhaps i didn't make that thoroughly
clear there
i have never felt uh that equities
should be the only portion of an
investor's
long-term program i myself am about 50
stocks 50
bonds for example i was brought up when
i came into this business in 1951 with
the wellington fund
which was and is and i hope always will
be a conservative balanced fund
but i think the idea of buying and
holding forever and not trying to make
adjustments
requires that you've gotten it right in
the first place
that you can only you can only hold
tight if you've bought right
if you will and that is to say have an
asset allocation
that has something to do with uh how
many years you have to accumulate money
how much resources you have at stake
uh how much income you need and how much
courage you have
to ride out the peregrinations of the
market so you've got to take all that
into account from that simple statement
you are the godfather of
index funds aimed at the average
investor
and this questioner points out that
actively managed funds have outperformed
and indexed over the last two years
is there a case then for market timing
what should you do when the index funds
are losing money
well as my friend jim glassman quoted me
in his
op-ed piece in the wall street journal
yesterday i quote i don't even remember
where i made but it said
um i don't know anybody who has ever
been successful
in uh timing the market i don't even
know anybody
who knows anybody who has ever been
successful in timing the market
uh last year these last two years the
the index uh s p indexes
outperformed roughly half of the funds a
little bit less last year just about
half this year
i don't regard that as a significant
long-term sign at all
first of all the number of funds is not
a relevant statistic we use it because
it's convenient
but if you've got a few little funds in
there that do well they count just as
much as a few big funds
the reality is no matter what the
statistics tell you
indexing always wins i say that because
index is delivering
the market return and all those
investors out there are by definition
getting the market return
themselves less cost so statistics don't
capture
that index advantage it will be
corrected in the next year or the next
year
and by the way if you look at the even
the last 15 years
counting those last two years the index
has outperformed about 75 percent of all
active managers
someone out there will want to take
careful notes here because we're going
to go from the
general to the very specific uh
for the past 15 months i've been
investing 1200
per month in schwab mutual funds
he or she doesn't say which schwab funds
should i continue or is there a better
place for that money these days
far be it for me to get even more in
more trouble with mr schwab than i'm in
already
uh but leaving leaving aside that you
know the infinite variety of a stock
of mutual funds they could be buying
through any kind of a mutual fund
marketplace like
charles schwab's uh the the answer is
yes
continue to invest i've told you
particularly young people in the office
who are really
petrified by this market decline that
it's the best thing
that ever happens to them if you think
about it logically of course it's
wonderful i mean think of
say the young man i was talking to you
yesterday is probably 25 or 26 years old
and he's got the rest of his life and
invest i said well let's let's suppose
that chris chris scott his name is i
said let's suppose chris
that the market's going to end up but
jim glassman's 36 000 by the time you
retire
do you want to be investing all your
money with the debt with the when the
dow is it
uh 35 000 or invest at all when it's 9
000. just think about that for a minute
or you want a long time to invest at low
prices
and it's a certainly a frightening
advantage for those of us who have some
money at work in the market today to
think that this is a blessing
but it is a blessing because in the long
run investing depends on accumulating
money at sound prices and not inflated
prices like we have
i also think the general economy and the
financial markets are well served
by a return to reality when you leave
reality and depart from the laws of
gravity
there's nothing but bad things that can
happen and the higher you fly the more
you fall we flew quite high enough
and i think it's a blessing maybe a
blessing and heavy disguise
a blessing that we've come back a little
bit toward the ground
speaking of coming back toward the
ground this investors stocks are really
down
dr coop just for feet
is that quickly pharmaceuticals uh
cisco lucent technologies should i sell
i haven't heard a list like that um he
even makes those tech funds i told you
about seem like heroes
uh i don't have any comment on those
individual stocks i mean
they are hugely depressed i think dr
coop i read the other day is endangered
because the stock is in danger of
becoming delisted
i think it's sold up in the mid 30s 30
is
and now is something like 19 cents yeah
it wasn't it wasn't a good turn
and it's very painful for people for
speculators
where people agreed overwhelm their good
judgment to get hurt
but will they bounce back i mean i guess
the answer to that group of stocks
without knowing much about quigley's
pharmaceutical
and being very nervous about dr coop is
you know companies like lucent will come
back
in time i don't think there's much
question about that but to own a handful
of individual stocks i don't think is
sound investing
and to obviously jump on the bandwagon
at a silly time
is uh you know i feel very very sorry
for the investor but
i don't know how to help him now him or
her you mean
like if i had bought a nasdaq indexed
fund 13 months ago
what will happen to tech funds will they
will they come back
we have similar questions for growth
funds value funds
are those three sectors going to rebound
are the three sectors growth value and
tech funds going to rebound and i guess
the answer is unequivocally yes
and the more interesting question is
when and how far
uh and and i you know it's very
difficult to answer
when because i think we're in for some
some tough weather here for a while i
think the steam
the confidence has gone out of of the
market and i think speculative
enthusiasm has
and well it held the market up and can't
hold it up forever
i've said to many groups that in this
kind of an environment if i was a
betting man
i would bet on value over tech or growth
other kinds of growth
but i quickly reassure them and you that
i am not a betting man
i just don't know how to do that so i
think if you're in heavily in technology
you should be gradually moving to
increase the value orientation
and if you're heavy heavily in value i'd
be gradually
believe it or not moving toward a growth
orientation i think technology is too
small a part
of the tune too narrow a part of the of
the overall investment economy
to be uh to be considered a separate
group so i would try to diversify if you
like growth
growth i'd rather be in growth generally
than just in technology
i will also tell you this without
without any fear that i'll be wrong at
all
and that is of these 71 technology funds
that were created in the first quarter
of last year
and if half of them are still in
business
five years ago uh i'll buy any number of
people here up to 10
a good cuban cigar or something
you've made it very clear that you are
neither a stock picker
nor an industry picker
nonetheless what industries do you think
might offer the most
attractive potential in the next five to
ten years
well another way to answer them and i
can't answer that because i just don't
know the answer to that
uh what you have to understand about the
market is is it comes just from what i
emphasized at the beginning from
investment return and speculative return
and the market is in the long run a very
brilliant
arbitraging medium which takes into
account the future prospects
and prices them accordingly so if i were
to tell you this industry let's say
healthcare for example or probably
technology will have a higher growth
rate
i'd feel very comfortable about that but
do the prices take into account
a lower growth rate and therefore will
be very good for you or are they
assuming a much higher growth rate than
technology can possibly achieve and
being bad
so i'd say i'm going to stick with my um
my mantra here
and that is avoid individual stocks and
avoid narrow stock groups
you see anywhere other than the u.s
equity markets that
is more attractive abroad
the question now is about non-u.s
markets outside of the u.s we call them
international markets and the industry
lower
more like foreign markets would be
better and i have to confess that i've
had a
bias against foreign markets for as far
back as i can remember
simply because they carry risks that are
not necessary to carry uh they carry
currency risk
and many of the particularly emerging
markets carry extreme
political risk uh extreme financial risk
very few nations in the world that have
the kind of protections for shareholders
the legal rights the ownership rights
that we have here in the united states
so i have a big bias
toward the u.s and i believe this will
continue to be the most productive
entrepreneurial innovative economy and
more rapidly growing economy than any in
the world
and i also point out quickly that when
you get out you don't need to
to leave u.s stocks have money outside
the us
and specifically that the that roughly
25
of the revenues and 25 percent of the
earnings of
u.s corporations come from abroad so i
don't think you need international
funds for that reason and i should say
there's been this sort of canard that
international funds would give you some
much needed diversification which is a
wonderful theory but if you look back at
the last year with the u.s stock market
down about 28
the international market is also down of
all things
28 percent international diversification
as a safety measure then
let us down just when we needed it most
so i do not think you need to depart the
us
one thing that has changed dramatically
during your watch on wall street
is who are investors
401ks have brought the vast
body of americans as individuals into
the market
has the spread 401 case affected market
psychology are
are these small investors more likely to
bail during a crisis
uh and what effect has it
has it had on the on the industry okay
the effect
of small investors or having the public
being the important part the in the
in investing public one might say the
great unwashed participating in the
stock market
has it in some sense made it more
speculative and uh
that reminds me actually of a um a
chapter i have in my original
senior thesis all those years ago where
i had some quotes from lord keynes
saying that as in institutional
investing took over the financial
markets there would be more
more emphasis on investment and less on
speculation
and you know that's what should have
happened but it didn't happen
when you're turning over your portfolios
like mutual fund managers and other
money managers 100
a year that's speculation that
short-term speculation that is not
long-term investing
so the public in spite of the fact they
aren't as knowledgeable they aren't as
expert they aren't as professional
uh is just as unwise as the
professionals
hopefully and it's meant many members of
the public of course i'm much wiser
and i guess i'd say index fund investors
for example
although institutions use index funds
very widely actually more than more than
the public uses them as well
so i think the biggest risk is that
investors who are not not accustomed to
being responsible for their own
retirement plans 401k investors for
example
usually have expecting the company to
take care of that are going to panic in
a market like this and get out i think
that's the biggest risk we face
because in the 401k area you can get out
of your stocks without cost
without tax cost without sales charges
it's very liquid and very quick
and liquidity in the market and you know
it's fine to have a liquid market but if
everybody wants their money out of the
stock market today
believe me nobody is going to get it so
uh by increasing liquidity in that way
i'm a little nervous about it but i
think it will be all right
and that leads to a policy question uh
president bush's
proposal to allow uh withdrawals to
direct investment uh for part of their
social security uh
uh uh funding uh this
uh to set a personal investments account
under the social security umbrella
what do you think of that
i'm always told i have very little
difficulty making my position clear
i think it is a very bad idea
and i think it's a bad idea i don't just
make these things up out of the top of
my head i think it's a bad idea for two
reasons one is economic
and by allowing people to take two
percentage points out of that twelve and
a half thirteen percent contribution
you will in fact will in fact there's no
argument about it this is not fuzzy math
you will in fact reduce contributions to
the social security program by one
trillion dollars over the next 10 years
that's a mathematical fact
and no doubt about it uh i think the
social security system and i think
everybody's ever thought about it thinks
the social security social security
system
needs either more funding or lower
payouts that the only way it's going to
work in the long run
so by taking lower funding uh the
payouts would have to go down even more
i think there have to be better
solutions than the social security plan
i furthermore think the plan is proposed
is economically uh
irresponsible and i think that for this
simple reason
that by that the retirement savings of
american investors
are too important to be left to the
wiles
of the mutual fund industry and i say
that for this reason
simple economics you having a lot of
small investors buy mutual funds in
their own social security
personal investment accounts is going to
cost more than that three percent
number that i gave you because handling
all those little checks is going to cost
a dollar here and 50 cents there and
little prices for this and that so it
might cost maybe four percent
so if the stock market gives an eight
percent return
the investor will get a four percent
return when the money in the government
bonds in the social security fund
is earning them six percent it must be
taking a risk and getting a lower return
and that doesn't make any sense to me
and those economics i think are beyond
challenge
in the same neighborhood compare and
contrast please
the proposed bush tax cut with the bogle
administration's tax policy
well uh unaccustomed as i am to public
speaking or something
uh but without a speechwriter either uh
let me say i think the the bush program
and
and particularly in light of the
economic circumstances and market
circumstances that have developed
and we're fundamentally i think in the
economy running into a risk that
confidence will be severely damaged
uh i think it's far too slow it has the
bush tax plan would do nothing for
investors this year
um so i i fall in on timing i also fall
for that even going down the road on
focus
i believe that the main portion of
benefits
both economically speaking and socially
speaking should go
to those with lower incomes i do not
believe i believe it is targeted too
heavily to the wealthy
and i don't think that's the appropriate
way to target it but not just because
i'm
a half communist if you want to argue
that but because i think the
i think that people are much more likely
to spend it are the people that need it
the most
so i think economically some form of
maybe tax rebate or something like that
uh would be a better way to go at this
particular stage
i also might as well get even more
trouble by saying i completely and
unorderably am opposed to the
elimination of the inheritance tax
uh i think that's absurd it's not
america to me
and uh even as i admit that not admit
but encourage
some inheritance tax relief larger
larger exemptions not just for family
farms and small businesses but for all
americans because i think all americans
not just those two groups
had deserved some inheritance tax relief
but not all the way up to a trillion
dollars that's a bit of a push
thank you very much we're going to ask
one more question but not
before we give you
a token of our appreciation for your
joining
us at the national press club this
certificate
and of course the coveted
national press club mug
well that's beautiful thank you so much
thank you
you faltered the president's uh
don't go too far away please you faulted
the president's proposed tax cut as
uh on grounds of uh targeting and cli
and timing
people have faulted the fed's
intervention
in the market in the financial markets
in monetary policy
as on grounds of timing
and degree uh too little too late
some have said uh how how do you assess
it a day after this
half percent that many expect to be
three-quarter
please
always glad to get back to the mic um
the uh i think we have given much to
uh it take given much to credence to the
possibility
that the fed is some and alan greenspan
is some you know giant buddha out there
that can preserve us from our earlier
mistakes and protect us from our future
errors
and i just i just don't believe that i
think monetary policy has an important
role to play in our economy
and honestly very little role to play in
our markets
the people that react to a half a point
or a three-quarter of a point if we get
that someday
a change in the discount rate are the
traders who are not
they the trader has no conviction about
whether it's good or bad the trader's
conviction is that other investors will
think that it's good or bad
it's just a big speculative market game
so
i i think alan greenspan has done just
about the right things most of the way
i think he feels a lot of pressure i
imagine he's not amused about what the
market did yesterday
but when we get a federal agencies
designed to hold up a market
i think we've taken our economic system
far further than it can be taken
and again thank you very much john c
vogel
i would like to thank all of you for
coming today i'd also like to thank
national press club staff members
melinda cook
pat nelson joanne boos melanie abdoul
dermot
and howard rothman for organizing
today's lunch also thanks to the npc
library for their research have a good
day
invest
be with well